a long time cbs franchise ncis has
launched a new series called ncis hawaii
and for the first time there is a woman
in the lead role she is actress vanessa
lachey she plays jane tennant a special
agent in charge of the pearl harbor team
in tonight's episode tenet and her team
worked to stop a group of international
thieves from using explosives in this
clip lachey's character interviews a
witness take a look
then help me understand why your truck's
gps was idle for two minutes on
farrington highway
you made an unscheduled stop carl had to
relieve himself it was like 30 seconds
it was two minutes
officers checked the area they didn't
find anything what happened there
nothing
been interviewed by
fbi hpd me you didn't tell anyone about
this he did it from time to time
bad prostate carl said it's not a big
deal kind of a big deal this time
melissa
carl was murdered
and vanessa lachey joins us now vanessa
welcome congratulations congratulations
can i say congrats to you guys this set
studio
1515 broadway has a whole new look i
love it did you get tingles when you
were coming down when i was driving i
did get i said to uh my girlfriend is
with me i was like i have this anxiety
feeling in my stomach butterflies but it
wasn't a good anxiety excitement because
this is memory lane for you you're old
stomping grounds like this
the old crl studio some of these cameras
still have trl uh tape on the side of
them i've noticed yeah i was wondering
if i signed i literally was trying to
think did i sign something before i left
but i'm looking at all of the decor it's
definitely been and you still look the
same oh
[Laughter]
let's talk about ncas why because okay
fill in our monitors here it's beautiful
you take ncas which people love you take
hawaii which is beautiful you put them
together it's a great show i have to say
it's a really great show and your
character is fantastic thank you i'm
honored uh this is the first time the
franchise has a woman in the lead as you
said
uh
well mark harmon started it and then
they went to ll cool j and uh chris
o'donnell and then scott bakula was nola
and um now i get the honor of being the
first female
they call them sack it's special agent
in charge and uh and let me tell you it
is quite an honor but your character's
such a badass because it opens with
she's on her kids are playing a sporting
event and then all of a sudden the
helicopter pulls up and she's like
mommy's gotta go you don't know who the
hell i got before yeah yeah you don't
know the helicopter you know it's
actually interesting i never even
thought about it but when you say how
can that be i think that
that's a good question to ask how can it
be but i like that i'm a part of it now
and this change of because there have
always been female women in ncis just
not on television and um now maybe this
is a tick in the right direction of
normalizing so this segment actually
prompted me to watch ncis for the first
time ever ever and i am completely
hooked and now i understand why the show
has been so strong for so many years
thank you uh you were very excited when
you got this role you posted to social
media a tearful clip do we have that
yeah we do
let's check it out i got the job
i was so happy
and i couldn't take the video because i
was okay what i don't know what to do i
don't know what to do
thank you i'm so happy
that that's what i call the ugly cry
vanessa oh it was that's the ugly cry
because it was very deep and very
sincere and that those tears seem to me
more than just i got this part
were they was it yes um
you know it's funny because when you say
it is an ugly cry and i remember my um
my social media i have a girl who helps
me lauren and she was like vanessa i
really think you should post this and
and that never crossed my mind to say oh
this is an ugly video it because it was
more than that to your point that was a
mother of three
who i've been in this industry for 20
years and
when people always talk about there's no
overnight success
people work in this industry in many
different avenues i've hosted i've done
behind the scenes i've done in front of
camera i've done a lot and this moment
was a culmination of all of that hard
work it was a culmination of covid and
questioning what am i who am i what am i
doing am am i a mother am i an actress
um a lot of time at home with my husband
we we had the hardest time in our
relationship which in turn became the
best time in our marriage and we're now
stronger than ever
and so i got this call it was uh
it was right after i got a call from cbs
that the show i did do for them was not
going to go
so talk about one door closing in
another one open two weeks later this
happened and it was just with my son in
the car i love that i could do it i
could do it it's hard to rewrite the
narrative of your career especially when
people put you in a box so i understand
why you were so emotional um i want to
get back to you hosting trl here though
um what memories come to mind cause you
guys talked to some absolute mega stars
mega stars uh honestly i think and you
did this actually just now gayle and i
sat on the swing you guys were working
just a minute ago in between the
commercial break and she sat next to me
just for it was like three minutes but
we just had an easy casual conversation
that's what i remember most is behind
the scenes there was a couch and i'm
telling you if there was a camera back
there that was the show those are the
stories that was the story that's when
they were real that's when they were raw
that's when it was it was it was magic
yeah well it's awesome it's a fantastic
show people tuning in cheering you on
i'm enjoying hanging out in virtual
hawaii here
vanessa thank you ncis hawaii airs
monday nights at 10 9 central on cbs and
is available to stream on the viacom cbs
streaming service paramount plus where i
am a viewer
yes vanessa we are all watching because
thank you